hmm
it is time now for CBS deals and this
morning we have several items that might
just tick that box for you whether it's
safety in the car or comfort for your
feet and all of it is exclusively low
priced to start shopping now scan the QR
code on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Elizabeth
Warner joins us with more she's back
from the pickleball court that's right
and she's having a great time
it's so good to see you so let's start
right off with jumpsmart I literally
just rescued my dad with this he was out
running errands his car wouldn't start
my husband and I drove 45 minutes got
there before the company he called for
help are you sick and jumped his car
this really works so yes jump smart so
this comes with the jumper cables so
everything you need to jump start your
vehicle car truck SUV also is a
flashlight with lots of different modes
an audible alarm and get this it's a
power source as well so for all the
people going through storms right now
losing their power you can charge all of
your devices with this this is so hard
to believe it can jump start yes we have
kids that are driving and they don't
leave without this they don't that's
right so these are really important now
right now they are 25 off just
119.99 which is amazing it comes with
everything you need the compass the
thermometer the reflector you name it
it's all in there wow I love that there
okay we got a peel here that's right
okay so 51 years old there are days
where I'm doing this right I'm in the
mirror I'm pulling my skin back is that
what I should on these days well it
doesn't work so here's what works all
right wrinkles chemicals I love this
these are silicone patches they're
medical grade they're made in the United
States you can put them on the forehead
they have them for under the eyes around
the mouth the neck the decollete you put
them on it boosts circulation it boosts
that collagen and you get that gorgeous
glow I have them all over my face and my
daughter came out looked at me a little
funny when we peeled them off she was
like wow Mom what a difference you look
amazing by the way 56 million people
have viewed a video on this on the
tickety talk so yeah it is incredibly
exactly they also have peels by the way
they're going to help you gently
exfoliate that skin and give you that
bright glow so all of these are amazing
how much and yes so these are on sale
right now 35 off from 9.99 up to 29.97
and female owned business Gabrielle
she's an amazing Beauty entrepreneur so
look at that Gabrielle what's her last
name
yes yes so we absolutely love amazing
all the work that she's done to make us
look beautiful I love it yes all right
so these are Dr Siegel's socks they're
compression and diabetic now my kids and
I have a medical condition so we have to
wear compressions okay all of us but a
lot of people were on their feet all day
the athletes I like it as a glove too
yeah they wear these to boost
circulation it decreases your chances of
blood clots thoughts it helps the
swelling in your feet and your ankles
and look how cute they are they're
stylish not only does he do compression
socks but the diabetic socks so my
grandpa was diabetic he had the right
shoes we went for the right pedicure he
didn't have the right socks so they
would cut off his circulation so these
have a nice stretchy band in them
they're anti-microbial they Wick away
that moisture so they keep the feet dry
and healthy if my grandpa had had this
it would have been so much easier he had
everything else going on but the socks
were too tight and so yeah amazing and
finally you can tell which socks in the
dress your compression socks are these
are the ones that I've been wearing
until now they're not fun they're not
cute great these are beautiful so right
now the deal price twelve dollars to
thirty dollars for these so amazing
Elizabeth thank you so much of course we
partner with all of these companies to
get these deals to buy anything you saw
today scan that QR code on your screen
or head on over to cbsdeals.com